leroux c'est maryse y à peine 700
habitants nichée dans la campagne de
saône et loire un petit village
tranquille même un peu trop tranquille
dans le centre-ville de nombreux
commerces ont fermé
c'est sur le territoire de cette commune
que le projet de center parcs pourrait
voir le jour avec 300 emplois à la clé
selon pierre et vacances je pense que
oui ça peut que dynamiser quoi on voit
nous serrer campagne et bien que j'aie
chose qui ferment moins en moins de
services de proximité donc effectivement
si ça peut apporter du monde et
développer des activités à côté de
center parcs non c'est surtout ça qui
m'intéresse dans ce projet ici les
quelques commerces de proximité qui
restent encore ouverts ne voient plus
passer grand monde en dehors de la
saison touristique
alors pour cette restauratrice le center
parcs ce serait l'assurance de travail
toute l'année
l'été si on a du tourisme quand même
beaucoup de beaucoup d'étrangers aussi
donc
mais c'est vrai que les lives et les
mois d'hiver sont plus plus dur quoi
donc si le thunder pas s'installer ce
serait vraiment positif ce serait
positif ray plus d'activité mais aussi
peut-être permettre de désenclaver un
secteur dont certaines zones ne sont
toujours pas couvertes par les
opérateurs téléphoniques une zone
blanche ici c'est moi qui viens nom du
région parisienne c'est quand même
pratique d'avoir un téléphone qui
captent surtout en 2018 c'est ici au
bord du lac du rousset que le parc
pourrait sortir de terre 86 hectares qui
pourront accueillir dans des énormes
piscine plusieurs milliers de touristes
chaque année sur le site bourguignon
pierre et vacances assure que l'écologie
est au coeur du projet et que
l'environnement sera préservé difficile
à croire pour les habitués du lac
ap ça c'est fini il va du monde un peu
partout il y aura des étaient alors les
gens qui sont autour qui sont à la
campagne et ou qui veulent être
tranquilles
il va y avoir du bruit de tous les côtés
n'importe quoi les opposants projet
devrait se faire entendre dans les jours
à venir
un rassemblement est prévu samedi
on